le mec fait son bilan de l'année fin
janvier et ça ne choque personne
le mec part en couille total on peut
quoi ils vont perdre tous ses abonnés
bravo bel exemple cyprien pour faute
initiale y tenait je vais revenir sur
tout ce que j'ai fait pendant l'année
2010 est parce que vous avez loupé plein
de trucs et désolé si je me prends
vraiment à ce parce que là j'ai eu pas
mal de boulot sur un très gros projet et
ça je vous en parle à la fin de la vidéo
le début de l'année 2017 a commencé
super fort avec ma vidéo pour les 10
millions d'abonnés c'est un tour du
monde où je vais rencontrer des gens un
petit peu partout sur la planète terre
c'est la vidéo la plus importante de ma
chaîne beaucoup de rencontres beaucoup
de voyages beaucoup de fatigue
il ya surtout le trophée des 10 millions
d'abonnés je suis très content d'avoir
sa petite anecdote le trophée de
vouvoyer à la fin de la vidéo de norman
c'est le mien voilà en parallèle de ma
vidéo des 10 millions d'abonnés j'y
travaillais sur mon court métrage qui
s'appelle le déménagement par une
thématique qui mettrait très proche
c'est le fait de se lancer vers des
choix risqué et j'en vois énormément
d'amour aux parasites qui ont réalisé
deux courts métrages et à slimane
baptiste café mondiaux ont fait la fiche
cascades tout est possible après un
court métrage et lancer un nouveau
concept sur ma chaîne youtube qui sont
les quizz voilà c'est des petites
dilution avec des guest sur les
thématiques d'internet et de youtube les
classes de faire ça c'était trop marrant
de faire une sorte de petite émission un
peu façon burger quiz et si vous en
voulez d'autres pour cette année 2010 8
n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les
commentaires
après ça j'ai réalisé mon sketch si le
président est élu du beurre et ses
sketches et la particularité d'avoir été
tourné devant la même feuille de décor
je m'explique le chant et le contrechamp
ont été tournées en fait au même endroit
on a juste l'inversé les regards on a
rajouté un petit drapeau et ensuite on a
inversé les mages et on a l'impression
que c'est des gens qui se parlent dans
la petite astuce de professeurs cyprien
voilà une vidéo sur les vieux la
technologie de leur tour parce que
j'adore les vieux j'adore la technologie
avec une séquence d'une bouée mais faire
sur les vieux qui appelle le service
après-vente pour leur box que votre
câble d'alimentation est bien branché
quelques jours après je sors la mise à
jour finale de mon jeu mobile gratuit le
nov aps oui voilà ça sans questions
débiles et ça a rendu fou des gens
devront passer par téléphone plusieurs
millions téléchargements et surtout
l'été dans le top 10 des jeux gratuits
sur l'appstore windu suis très content
ma bd et roger et c'est humain a été
traduite en anglais one woman show ces
le titre en anglais sur ses atouts cool
après ça ma vidéo sur les gens sur
internet site a pas d'âme pas sur
twitter et c'est ma centième vidéo sur
ma chaîne
c'est un peu un symbole c'est dix fois
moins que ce que vous dit peut-être que
j'ai un peu un peu plus qu'eux on arrive
à l'été 2010 est hélas or deux très gros
projet ça faisait longtemps que je
bossais dessus des mois d'écriture et de
préparation d'abord ma mini série avec
nanou et norman qui s'appelle presque
adulte qui est sorti sur tf1 et sur
youtube et ma série audio l'épopée
temporel j'en ai déjà parlé sur ma
chaîne
un de ces deux projets donc ne pas
revenir dessus mais en tout cas je vais
juste vous remercier continuer à
regarder les projets qui sont assez
différents de ce qu'on peut voir sur la
chaîne youtube de continuer à être
curieux merci à vous et vous pouvez
regarder sur youtube dès à présent c'est
pas déjà fait on arrive
or 11 millions d'abonnés pour fêter ça
j'ai ramené des petits objets farfelus
du japon avec un énorme travail
d'investigation et de recherche sur les
objets les plus perché de l'histoire de
l'objet perche et j'ai farfouillé
partout à tokyo pour vous trouvez ça et
on va tester tout ça avec norman et
squeeze donc merci à eux à la fin de
l'été je pars 24 heures à new york pour
samsung
alors c'est très bizarre de changer de
continent juste pour une journée voilà
c'est pas mal de décalage un peu chelou
mais j'ai bien profité de la ville et
vous pouvez voir la vidéo sont
page facebook avec lucas on a participé
à l'émission de fort boyard voilà
c'était ma deuxième fois que je pense
avoir fait la séquence la plus ridicule
de l'histoire avec moi qui tiens pas une
demi seconde sur un vélo regardez je
suis là
j'ai disparu
moquez vous bien sympa les gars on
arrive à la rentrée
ça commence très fort avec l'avant
première de la fin de l'été temps pour
être dans un cinéma très classe merci à
tous ceux qui sont venus j'ai bossé en
scred pour aussi relancé ma marque
marmol voilà avec plein de nouveaux
produits ceci par exemple vous avez été
très nombreux à l'avoir demandée on a
fait les réunions 3 pour l'épisode
d'avant en guest on a eu à libourne qui
était super sympa et en 2017
on a eu de nombreux noirs qui a été
adorable c'est mon épisode préféré des
réunions on a tellement riche perso j'ai
rencontré alain chabat voilà c'est un
moment important dans ma vie mais c'est
un petit peu ma référence en blu ray je
crois que ça se voit un bon visage on
arrive à la fin de l'année 2017 avec lui
car vous a préparé un clip sur nos dix
jeux préférés de l'année et en même
temps pendant l'année j'ai passé une
tête chez les potes sur plein de chaînes
youtube notamment sur la chaîne de
julien pestel de acino m'irrite youtube
le clip haut-var watch de lucas what the
fuck france coco boîte plus petits brise
puis je monte dans ma twingo
car la route n'a pas donné plus tard
mais comment sa femme avait envoyé plein
de fans art magnifique merci beaucoup ça
a égayé toute cette année
et maintenant parlons de mon prochain
gros projet qui explique pourquoi je
suis en retard sur ce bilan de l'année
depuis plusieurs mois je travaille sur
mon prochain court-métrage qui s'appelle
lunaire on vient de terminer le tournage
ça s'est super bien passé c'était mortel
je suis très content d'avoir partagé ça
avec des comédiens top avec eux raphaël
des cracks à la réalisation c'est un
projet avec des thématiques qui sont
très personnelles pour ça que ce court
métrage est très important pour moi ça
sort en février donc j'espère que ça va
vous plaire et que vous allez répondre
présent merci beaucoup pour cette année
2010 est de m'avoir accompagné dans tous
ses projets farfelus ci s'est passé
plein de choses sur sur ma chaîne et
ailleurs je vous prépare pas mal de
choses pour l'année 2018 a commencé par
prochain court-métrage et je vous dis à
très vite
[Musique]